on monday there was one comment taylor
swift couldn't shake off you never know
what it's going to be the singer became
the center of a recent profile on damon
albarn while speaking with the los
angeles times the publication asked for
the blur frontman's thoughts on today's
musicians
and when it came to taylor he said quote
she doesn't write her own songs the
comment followed the reporter mentioning
that swift is a writer and co-writer in
response damon replied that doesn't
count i know what co-writing is
co-writing is very different to writing
and well taylor caught wind of the
comments on twitter quote tweeting the
la times she wrote quote damon albarn i
was such a big fan of yours until i saw
this i write all of my own songs your
hot take is completely false and so
damaging you don't have to like my songs
but it's reliefed up to try and
discredit my writing wow she replied to
her own tweet ps i wrote this tweet all
by myself in case you were wondering
damon commented on taylor's tweet
following the backlash
he replied i totally agree with you i
had a conversation about songwriting and
sadly it was reduced to clickbait i
apologize unreservedly and
unconditionally the last thing i would
want to do is discredit your songwriting
i hope you understand damon
taylor has yet to respond to damon's
apology
the best advice i've ever gotten
was to
be kind to people swifties came out in
full force to support the all-too-well
singer
including taylor's longtime collaborator
jack antonoff
the bleachers frontman tweeted i've
never met damon albarn and he's never
been to my studio but apparently he
knows more than the rest of us about all
those songs taylor writes and brings in
[Music]
the fans keep raising the bar so for me
like it makes me want to raise the bar
on the music i'm making over the years
taylor shared with e.t why songwriting
is so important to her there's just sort
of a little extra little bit of pride
involved when you've written a song by
yourself and
i like to write songs about boys and
relationships and things that i've
actually gone through
[Music]
i tend to
include details and uh the entire story
because for me the most fun part about
this the most intriguing part about
music is the storytelling that's woven
into it with the lyrics
[Music]
when you go through something
this life that i live where you write
songs about things that even the things
that don't work out it it's kind of like
a justification system you're like you
know what that didn't work out but
it was worth something because it made
me feel something
[Music]
you